I didn't talk to the guy I didn't care
about the bus Whoopi Goldberg on why she
chose not to contribute to the view tell
all ladies who punch have you read the
book about the view no no and any did
you hear about the talk about the book
no because what happens for me at work
is not for everybody it's not their
business the 63 year old talk show host
opened up about the situation on
Thursdays watch what happens live with
Andy Cohen I don't like talking out of
school and I don't like other people
talking at school so Rosie had some
strong words about you is it is it
that's okay we'll be also dished on
getting high with her fellow co-host of
you co-host would be the least fun to
get high with oh heavens to Betsy I
should I think they'd all probably be
really fun to get high way yes but they
don't get high on a more serious note et
caught up with Whoopi earlier this month
at the 2019 Tribeca Film Festival
premiere of her new documentary Waldo on
the weed where she opened up about her
near-death health crisis was very scary
you know nobody wants to find out that
they're actually close to death it's
just you know those are not words you
really want to hear so it's low as a
longtime supporter of cannabis will be
revealed she's no longer able to smoke
from her beloved vape she named sippy
I'm not allowed to vape anymore because
I was I got had pneumonia as I said it
was double pneumonia and sepsis and all
kinds of stuff and so the doctors like
you can't you your isn't too soon I
think it's important for people to know
how good cannabis can work for lots of
different things and in children in
particular because I would rather offer
a child this way to heal themself
as opposed to taking the pillows and the
things that really can ruin a child
stomach and I dick them you know it just
doesn't happen with this and so I kind
of feel like you can't be willfully
ignorant about stuff like health and
alternatives to some of the really harsh
drugs that you know people are crying
about now saying you know there's opioid
well yeah we're telling you how we can
help people not get addicted is by using
something that's actually grown in the
ground
[Music]